apocalyptic scenes from california in
the summer of 2020 the most destructive
wildfire season in that state's history
by the end of the year nearly 10
000 individual blazes had claimed 33
lives and burned an area
large enough to fit berlin the city of
berlin 12 times
california is no stranger to battling
wildfires even so
no one expected the sheer size speed and
ferocity
of the flames in 2020.
now in 2021 californians are bracing for
the next fire season a season that
started
early it appears because of a deliberate
act
police arrested an arson suspect after a
wildfire
broke out near topanga state park north
of los angeles
facing steep and difficult terrain fire
crews were supported by helicopters and
air tankers
on the ground local authorities gave
evacuation orders to hundreds of homes
under threat
the area's dense vegetation has not seen
a major burn
in more than 60 years that helped drive
the flames despite the cool conditions
and with almost no wind here's the los
angeles
fire chief i think we really have to
think about brush
fires as a year-round challenge and
uh yesterday when i woke up it was
raining
and it was raining out here and the fire
is still burning
and that is unusual fire behavior
that tells you that the drought that the
years of
of um that have gone by before the
since the last fire sometimes as long as
75 years
have changed the equation all right
let's go now to our very own
stefan simons he joins me from pacific
palisades in the hills above los
angeles good afternoon to you stefan so
what's the situation there are you
standing
in a powder keg
yeah you could say so let me fill you in
and prep this scene here for you
what you see behind me here this is
actually the palace hits fire this is
the pacific palace it's neighborhood
here
and around that bend you see all those
fire trucks there well they're going
up that hill all the way there's dozens
more dozens and dozens
in total there is 50 fire trucks
involved in fighting this fire here 535
firefighters and
you see those those uh uh green trucks
here dalton
hot shots this is a in an elite fire
crew those guys are
working 16-hour shifts 16-hour shift
up there in the hills working the line
meaning clearing the brush
making sure the fire is not coming
towards this homes
those homes we spoke to residents here
and they spent
the last three four days actually
absolutely frightened and terrified
talked to a woman who said like she
hasn't slept in three or four days
and uh and she looked really tired so i
believe her
it's not a good situation here but good
news no more evacuations the equation
orders and warnings are lifted now
um la fire and la county fire seem to
have a grip
on the fire here now you know we've
heard that some areas in california
they haven't had a burn off in years
there's been a build
up of thick brush and forest debris
do officials there do they see a need
for better forest management to prevent
fires on the scale that we saw last year
i think they do i know that the
officials from the forest service here
and they are actually responsible for
making those counter burns right those
control burns to
to get rid of the brush in all of this
they are a little frustrated they feel
they're they're getting uh
a bad reputation here they are doing
this i mean 165 000
a square feet were burned last year in a
controlled burn
of course residents here they tell you a
different story they say this
the state has to do more and now big
surprise follow the money
the more money you spend on forest
management on fire fighting etc etc
the more results and better results you
get the governor has now proposed an
increase of
billions and billions of dollars for
exactly that because california is you
know it looking at one of the worst fire
seasons
probably to come i got 30 seconds for
you is it true what the los angeles fire
chief said that
fire season is basically the entire year
now
yeah it's pretty much the conclusion
here that
this is not gonna go away uh all year
it's an
almost an all-year event and the reason
given for this is
in california anybody you asked tells
you that climate change
it's getting hotter there's a drought
there's no rain not enough rain
everything is a tinder box here and can
you light in a second
all right stefan simons in the pacific
palisades in the hills above los angeles
where yeah it's easy to start a fire
these days
stefan thank you
you